después de la caída de precipitaciones
de meses en solo dos días los cielos
parcialmente azules parecen la luz al
final del túnel en la columbia británica
en lo que se ha descrito como un
acontecimiento meteorológico único las
tormentas torrenciales azotaron la
provincia canadiense el lunes y el
martes dejando algunas ciudades
inundadas y provocando desprendimientos
de tierra en otras miles de personas de
toda la región fueron evacuadas y se
enviaron helicópteros a las zonas más
afectadas para rescatar a las personas
que habían quedado atrapadas durante
horas sin agua ni comida el alcalde de
abbotsford donde se evacuaron a más de
1100 hogares describió la tormenta como
la peor que ha visto en la región en
casi 70 años
las inundaciones y los desprendimientos
de tierra han dejado muchos evacuados
familia y amigos se están volcando para
ayudar y ya se han registrado más de 80
familias en nuestro centro de acogida
las autoridades advierten que el número
de víctimas puede ser alto mientras
continúan en los operativos de búsqueda
y rescate las inundaciones también
obligaron a cerrar varias vías
ferroviarias oleoductos y el mayor
puerto de canadá en vancouver lo que
probablemente dificultará el suministro
de productos básicos durante varios días
razón por la que los ministros del
gabinete provincial planean reunirse y
sopesar si declarar el estado de
emergencia en toda la provincia por su
parte el primer ministro justin truck
dijo que el gobierno federal
proporcionará la ayuda que sea necesaria